now then there may not be a date for a
referendum yet but the battle lines are
already being drawn over Britain's
membership of the European Union key
business figures politicians and even a
former head of the army have been
pinning their colours to the mast last
week saw the launch of a second exit
campaign to with the cross-party vote
leave but it's competing against a rival
group leave dot EU which has the backing
of you Kip the party's leader Nigel
Farage joins me now very good morning to
morning guys I mean and that's the
simplified version of what's going on
with you there's a lot of campaigns on
the ladies right you're wrong your
introduction is wrong I support every
campaign what aliens I support every
camera that was get Britt out of the
European Union you know I mean I'm not
gonna be partisan about this and say
I'll pack this group over that group
I'll back everybody that wants us to be
outside the European Union the point is
you know it's been sort of put that the
leave campaign is divided their two
completely different campaigns you know
one the leave da tu campaign has got
200,000 people signed up to it it's non
party political and it's trying to reach
millions of voters the other which is
vote leave is a Westminster based group
making business arguments they're
completely different okay actually but I
think they complement you know but but
just so happened to be in the vote leave
the Westminster base one is your own EMP
and colleague double using you as well
what he's in Westminster and he's with a
group of people he's worked but he's not
on your wife at ease I'm not an acre
good please can we get this straight I'm
not in any campaign I'm the leader of
you Kip we are out all over the country
holding public meetings campaigning I
mean gateshead tomorrow night doing it
there are two groups who've set
themselves up to the umbrellas I support
both of them but they're both completely
different but the issue of leadership
does loom I mean in terms you're a
seasoned campaigner you know you saw in
the general election we've seen it in
the referendum campaign is cotton the
public who have to make the decision
yeah need to get their handle on someone
a figurehead someone leading this well I
campaign that's you isn't it in the
public's mind you are most associated
with that mastic to be honest with you
it needs to be several people and I'm
sure when we see the in campaign
no they're not going to have just one /
okay Stuart Rose is heading it up but
he's not the only guy that's kind of
appear on your program they'll be other
spokesman and spokeswomen for them as
they will be for our side of the
campaign I need you Kip with the people
that have forced this referendum on to
the agenda we're going to be out doing
our thing and we will work with anybody
but I think what's really important
what's being forgotten here is there are
millions of people out there who don't
normally vote in referendums who could
be brought in to vote if we're prepared
to talk about believing in our country
and controlling our borders there's also
a whole sway the people on the left of
politics all right whoo-hoo potentially
are you're a skeptic and who are not
going to be attracted to a Westminster
base campaign which is mostly run by
conservatives so we need different
elements to all of this okay so it's a
it's mixed message then danger coming
across then is if you're not going to
use lives you're not going to unify the
message because you also left out of it
mr. prizes the groups that so far as
saying we're waiting for the
renegotiation state place yeah we don't
know which way will go we might go know
if we don't like what the primary think
well it's well the auditor that's quite
simple what renegotiation it's pretty
clear last week when I met the French
president that there is no there is no
renegotiation and if you look at today's
Sunday Telegraph you've just been
through the reviews you know what the
British government are asking for
frankly is nothing I'm it up at the
heart of this there are lots and lots of
arguments at the heart of this recent
ICM poll showed fifty two percent would
vote to stay in the European Union if we
could control our borders if we can't
control our borders that falls to
thirty-six percent just let me ask you
about that because you mentioned it I
mean it was extraordinary footage I
watched when you delivered your your
speech there in front of mr. Hollande
especially you called him a pipsqueak
you call this country at a pipsqueak
yeah how did that translate that into
French i'm not sure what the translators
made it i mean we you know 25 years ago
when we were pushing towards you know a
political european union pushing towards
a single currency france and germany had
equivalent strength the point I was
making is that now it is a completely
German dominated European so are we pick
squeaks to in the UK as well because
we're still in the EU dominated by the
German quite frankly what what mrs.
Merkel says is what happens and that
happens you know whether it's to do with
euro whether it's to do with the
migration crisis she is very much in
charge let me get back to the leave II
want the campaign to get out yeah you
took their about figures on the left
there are figures within the
Conservative Party I mean Jeremy Corbyn
has said well you know he's not entirely
sure about the European Union could you
see figures like that well Jeremy Corbyn
for 40 years has been against Britain
being a member of the European Union he
was a he was a fan of Tony Benn nobody
made the Democratic argument against
being members of the European project
better than tony benn benn was a great
Patriot believe that we should govern
our own country not surrender control of
our Parliament and our courts elsewhere
and Corbin we all know that Corbin wants
to leave the EU but he finds himself the
leader of a party and within that
parliamentary party who have been almost
completely taken in by the European
project so he's he's backed off sadly
it's a shame how do you think he could
still be convinced obviously I share a
platform with you but what's going on
the note what Jeremy coughing but well
my position is I think this is the most
important question we're going to face
in our lifetimes I think left-wing
politics and right-wing politics are
irrelevant compared to the issue of do
we control our own country do we control
our own borders I'd share a platformer
pretty much anybody including Jeremy
called of course well you weren't would
you share one with Lord Lawson who's on
on your side it seems but um says why
doesn't he doesn't have any dealings
with the xenophobia rd he was referring
to you identify posh enough for him but
I but a bit but despite you know being
abused which I'm pretty used to I would
still share a platform with them of
course I would I want to win this
referendum I'm not interested in
factionalism I'm not interested in party
tribalism I want to win this referendum
and spend we've left out addressing now
elements of the Conservative Party there
are many within the Conservative Party
or already I know you've been speaking
to them you recruited one of them they
are outers I think a lot of the
Conservative Party is in that position
and what is really clear is that the
Conservative Party are bitterly bitterly
split over this perhaps they have been
for four decades but on the one hand
you've got cameron and osborne who
basically
i'm going to offer us the status quo and
on the other you've got Boris and
Theresa May making demands that look
pretty impossible so I think mr.
Cameron's in for a very tough time I'm
certain that of the Conservative Party
in the country well over half of them
now want to leave the EU Boris Johnson
to be a feather in the act cap wouldn t
well we might just get it we might just
get him and he's a recognizable figure
and that would be good news ok mr farage
very good to see thank you very much
lead you Kip need a Nigel for hours
there